hey guys Pete here it's time for my
Watchmen Episode 7 trailer breakdown the
episode is titled an almost religious
awe which is the first one I haven't
been able to pin down as far as where it
comes from it may be connected to the
author William Walker Atkinson who was
influential in the new thought movement
in the late 19th and 20th century but I
can't say for sure this video will break
down the official HBO promo for episode
7 scene-by-scene
and it will contain spoilers for
everything that's happened in the series
thus far I'm also gonna talk about the
supplemental materials theories other
trailers that have been put out in the
original graphic novel throughout so
you've been officially warned for
spoilers I have to mention the
Supplemental materials from the PDP dia
before I jump into the trailer in a memo
they released which was written by Lori
we learned that while she was on her a
nostalgia trip that Angela was talking
the whole time essentially everything we
learned watching episode 6 Laurie knows
as well that includes the fact that will
Reeves hypnotize chief Crawford to hang
himself Laurie's on her way to interview
the Chiefs wife and she sent agent P D
to go find lookingglass and bring him in
the episode 7 trailer opens with the
flashback scene to Saigon in the 1980s
the first shot is a street scene that
doesn't give away much in the way of
details there's a closing shop with some
street vendors out in front of it there
is a sign that says 89 which probably
gives away the year but the dates on the
Vietnam part of the story are a little
bit confusing as far as I can tell since
we're gonna find out what year it is in
a couple of days I don't think it really
seems like something I want to explore
here the next shot is of Angela and her
grandmother Jun sitting together in a
cafe we know it's June because we saw
her at the end of the last episode she
says tell me something about yourself
Angela to which she replies I'm going to
be a police officer it sounds like
they're just getting to know each other
for the first time the place looks
western rather than Vietnamese based on
what we see on the table which could be
interesting but the fact that they meet
each other and Angela knew she wanted to
be a police officer from an early age
seemed like what's important as far as
this scene is concerned we see that the
badge says Saigon police officer then
there's a flash of scenes first
we have Angela's parents smiling it
looks like Marcus is in the army and
that could explain why they live
overseas we met Marcus a bar as a child
in the last episode which gave some
context to the speech he gave to his
daughter about masks in the comic-con
trailer he said people who wear masks
are dangerous you should be scared of
them
Angela asked why and he says because
they're hiding something
Marcus knows this because he's will son
and he saw how that got in the way of
his parents relationship from there we
see two saigon police officers in front
of angela i guess here is as good a time
as any to point out that the vietnam she
grew up in is probably very different
than the one in our world
first of all Saigon isn't called that
anymore after the unification it was
renamed Ho Chi Minh City we see that
they have the 51 star American flag on
their uniforms and it stands out that
one of the officers is female because
that would have been very unlikely in
the 80s in real world Vietnam that cuts
to a flash of Crawford's badged with the
drop of blood and then a shot of young
Angela looking at something off screen
the look and the police officers make me
think that this is probably related to
her parents dying when she was little
that could also be why Jun showed up or
she may have been inspired to become a
police officer because of this female
police officer she met at this time I
can't remember her giving details on how
her parents died but this feels like it
could be related to an accident
from there we come back to the present
we see Angela's staring and here lady
true saying her name and voiceover we
hear lady T say I have a secret plan to
save humanity and it starts in Oklahoma
there's a sequence of shots including
one from the top of the millenium clock
looking down on the by barium which is
connected to a large building a couple
of shots of Angela looking at a large
globe we see are looking at the US and
Tulsa where they are in the season 1
trailer we saw some of these images with
lady T saying you need to help stop the
7th cavalry to which Angela responded
from doing what so in this period of
time when she's there we can imagine
that she'll explain her plan to save
humanity and perhaps how it involves the
7th Calvary and what they're planning to
do
I'll come back to lady true after the
scene-by-scene because we got a lot of
new information about her from the PD
files next we see Angela asked what does
this have to do with my treatment and
watch lady T injects something into her
arm through the medical device we see
her wearing throughout the trailer
angela looks worried about what's
happening and we get a close-up of her
eyes this is definitely the coolest
transition of the trailer as we see her
eyes turn to stained glass windows which
turn out to be in the room or Adrian
Veidt is on trial in his prison on
Europa Adrian is decked out in his full
Ozymandias costume not surprisingly most
everyone we see is a Phillips or cook
shanks there's a jury in a gallery full
of them and some of the photos that HBO
released of this that looks like there
may be some different people different
actors in the background but I don't
know for sure we hear all rise for the
game warden and see that Adrian is the
only one who doesn't stand up he's
definitely got shackles on that might be
the reason but overall we see his face
several times and he looks pretty
uninterested in the proceedings the game
warden who's just another Philips with a
mustache and a mask is sitting on the
bench and says if you have anything to
say in your defense say it now there's
not much new here as we've seen several
indications that this was gonna go down
I'll talk more about the trial after the
scene-by-scene because most of this
stuff comes from different trailers then
we see it flash on the screen the text
only three episodes left I was a little
bit gutted when I saw that when that
idea hit me that there's only three
episodes left in that sequence it
appears that Agent P D has arrived at
looking-glasses bunker there was a
different shot of this in previous
trailers where we see dead 7k members on
the ground both just have Dale looking
around with the flashlight with no sign
of LG though either way it looks like
we're gonna find out what happened at
the end of LG's episode there's a shot
of a truck getting into an accident with
a car at first I thought this was his
truck but on closer inspection it looks
unrelated after that there's a shot of
what looks like a pretty big explosion
there's a guy who doesn't look like
anyone we know in the foreground and not
much else I'd like to point out here
that it says something about a show when
you can have an image like this in the
trailer and have no idea what it might
be if I had
guess I would say this might be related
to the 7k and their watch batteries and
teleporters but it could really be
anything it could be at any time from
there we see Angela is up and walking
around by herself she bangs on the door
and it appears she's looking for her
grandfather she says I know you're in
there I took your pills and then she
pushes her way in she looked surprised
that whatever she discovers inside but
we can't see what it is and the trailer
ends there the trial looks fun and we
can start there
we know that bike got himself in trouble
with the game warden when he tried went
outside of his boundaries but what is
the point of the actual trial based on
other images we've seen it looks like
evidence will be presented about the
squid and I'm not sure what that says
about what they're trying to accomplish
or who actually put him there in the
first place the most likely candidates
are dr. Manhattan or lady true both have
the power to do this but it isn't clear
why they would go to these lengths based
on what we know we're missing a piece of
this puzzle that the game warden is
played by Tom Mison who plays Phillips
is interesting because he behaves like
he was created for a different role but
I'm not sure that makes either candidate
more likely at this point what's
exciting about this trial is that we'll
learn more about what's going on because
this story will have to play out in the
next two episodes and if you're worried
that this is going nowhere I'll put a
couple of links in the description to
interviews where Lindelof assures us
that we will find out how Adrienne's
story connects to what's going on in
Tulsa one big question I was left with
after watching this trailer was how or
why is angela at lady trues a simple
explanation could be that after taking
wills nostalgia she had to be treated
with her own memories or something that
they developed for situations like these
true would be the person to talk to
about nostalgia and the side effects of
taking a massive dose of it made for
someone else we did learn a lot of
things about her from the PD files sort
of I say sort of because this article is
presented as a gossip column where they
throw out a bunch of rumors about the
trillionaire and her assistant responds
to me it sounds like the assistant is
probably being who plays her daughter
one of the biggest revelations is that
lady tees mother wrote a
book about parenting and that her name
was also being I looked into this and
it's not common to name a child after
your ancestors in Vietnamese culture
it's actually the opposite of how we do
it in the West it would be avoided as it
wouldn't be considered respectful for
the deceased ancestors this feels like
it fits with the theory that BN could be
a clone of Lady T's mother which people
have been talking about since she had
the dream about her village being burned
when she was hooked up to the IB what's
really funny about this article is that
the writers came together and thought
about the theories that we would come up
with us fans and then use those as the
questions they asked questions like is
the Millennium Clock really a time
machine and whether the comedian is Lady
trues father by giving the kind of
answers an assistant would give to a
gossip column they can really play with
us for example the assistant doesn't
directly deny that the comedian is trues
father but says they did meet during the
war saying that his battalions uniquely
warm demeanor made quite an impression
on her
so they addressed the fan theory that
Eddie Blake was true father and inject
the idea that he probably just burned
her village in reality there's a lot of
background information she has for
Doctorate degrees she earned by the time
she was 15 years old there an
astrophysics nuclear fission nano
chemistry and bioengineering she became
a billionaire from creating nostalgia
and settled the large class-action suit
that happened after people started
abusing it she launched 50 Voyager Class
probes into the galaxy which could be
related to the satellite Adrian Veidt
was trying to signal for help I wish I
could say all this information makes it
clear what Lady trues plans are in my
opinion it doesn't one bit of
information that jumps out is that she
has sent everyone in the tri-county area
around Tulsa a brand new HDTV since
she's working with will who is in
possession of mind control technology
this could be fairly important the two
most popular theories about Lady T's
plans were one an empathy bomb or some
sort of event that would make the world
a better place and two that she just
once revenged for the Vietnam War the
motivations for each idea are pretty far
apart nothing in this article points us
decidedly in either
rection we also know a lot more about
will after the last episode but beyond
wanting to wipeout cyclops it's not
clear how his ideas have evolved over
the years or how he came to be working
with lady T in the first place we know
he used the mind-control device to get
drug to kill himself and that the FBI is
currently trying to track him down for
that we know that in 1955 senator Keens
father gave the Marshall feats of
Comanche horsemanship painting to
Crawford's father as a passing of the
torch kind of gesture signing the letter
with the cyclops symbol we know that
King jr. and Crawford were pulling the
strings behind the scenes for the
seventh Cavalry and that they are
staging something that's going to happen
soon it's a lot of different factions
and a lot of balls in the air and I'm
excited to see where things go the other
big mystery of the trailer is what
Angela will discover when she pushes her
way into that room I've seen ideas like
evidence of cloning a grandfather or
other new technology related to her
endgame if you've listened to the
official podcast from HBO Damon Lindelof
said we won't find out what crashed on
the farm until the finale so I guess we
can roll that out
but everything else seems to be on the
table and it feels like it's going to be
an important piece as to what lady T is
actually up to I'm gonna wrap this up
here let me know in the comments what
you think after watching this trailer
what are you excited about for episode 7
where are you sitting with the theories
and the mysteries that we have going
around only three episodes left so we're
gonna be getting some answers please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already thanks for watching we'll talk
to you soon